[Musique]
la mauvaise nouvelle est arrivée dans
leur boîte aux lettres la valeur du
duplex de Laurent Servet et Philippe
Bodin dans shlaga Maisonneuve agrippé de
près de 200000 dollars maintenant c'est
évalue à 600 4400 dollars l'augmentation
de 40
47 % je pense les taxes municipales sont
calculés en fonction de la valeur des
propriétés qui est révisée tous les
trois ans la Ville de Montréal vient de
compléter l'exercice pour le rôle
foncier 2023 2025 la hausse est de 35%
en moyenne dans le secteur résidentiel
la date de référence utilisée pour les
calculs et le 1er juillet 2021 le marché
immobilier était alors en pleine
ébullition on fait deux choses pour
s'assurer qu'il y a pas de trop gros
choc financiers pour les citoyens des
citoyens d'abord on étale le rôle sur
trois ans donc ce qui permet d'abord une
hausse qui est graduelle et la deuxième
chose fait c'est qu'on descend le taux
de taxe au final ce sont les
propriétaires qui ont vu la valeur de
leur résidence augmentée davantage que
la moyenne comme Laurence et Philippe
qui verront leur compte de taxes grimper
le plus dans leur cas la dernière
facture s'élevait à 3400 dollars je
m’attends à 500$ par année
d'augmentation de texte c'est une
dépense supplémentaire qui s'ajoute à
tout le reste vraiment tout ce qu'on
avait là pour acheter pour plus être
locataire de mes propriétaires comme je
t'ai dit 40 à 45% de notre budget il
passe ce qui est quand même plus élevé
que ce qui est recommandé cette
augmentation le voit mais des décisions
au moins de sortie tout c'est sûr moins
de restos pour établir la valeur des
propriétés la ville examine environ
25000 transactions immobilières par
année c'est donc le prix de vente de ces
immeubles qui sert à déterminer la
valeur de tous les autres le service
d'évaluation dégage des indices de
variation des valeurs par
présidentielle commercial industriel et
par localité mais ce processus
d'évaluation de masse n'est pas sans
faille il ne tient pas compte des
particularités qui pourraient faire
baisser la valeur d'une résidence les
infiltrations
problèmes de fondation ou encore des cas
où il y a eu un entretien
négligé de la propriété et dans
l'éventualité on voulait la mettre en
vente par exemple on se dirait bon on a
des travaux à faire les propriétaires
qui se stimulent lésés peuvent contester
leur évaluation foncière en 2017 ils
sont plus de 2700 l'avoir fait et 56%
d'entre eux ont obtenu une révision à la
baisse de la valeur de leurs propriétés
en 2020 c'était 46% bref le jeu peut en
valoir la chandelle le système a été
fait sur la base de je visite votre
maison ou 9 ans mais leur sa visite plus
alors si l'évaluateur il peut pas venir
ça fausse un peu le portrait d'ensemble
puis ça ça induit des erreurs qui font
que plus de gens insatisfaits avec son
groupe Montréal pour tous pierre pager
aide les citoyens qui veulent contester
leur évaluation la démarche coûte 75$
pour ceux qui ont un immeuble qui vaut
500000 dollars et moins c'est 300
dollars pour les propriétés qui valent
entre un demi et 2 millions j'ai payé
moins que 20 000 dollars pour la maison
Albanie Morin a fait l'exercice deux
fois par le passé et obtenu gain de
cause en 2014 la ville a réduit la
valeur de son duplex du
Plateau-Mont-Royal de près de 114000
dollars et de 37000 dollars trois ans
plus tard je vais pas faire de
rénovation depuis 89 alors
me comparer à des maisons où on a fait
des rénovations récentes au coude
aujourd'hui
me mettre au même niveau ça tient pas
ces baisses de valeur lui ont fait
épargner des centaines voire des
milliers de dollars en taxe municipale
c'est une personne retraité j'ai mes
revenus sont fixes elle ne sait pas
encore si elle contestera de nouveau son
évaluation cette année je peux faire
tous les préparatifs
demandés à la ville de donner les
comparables et voir si ça vaut la peine
c'est un exercice il y a la préparation
à faire chaque dollar compte et on a
beaucoup d'empathie pour ces personnes
là mais il faut se dire également que on
reçoit des services on donne des
services à la ville pour cet argent là
et nous aussi depuis des années
on encaisse l'effet de l'inflation
d'un côté la Ville de Montréal a besoin
des revenus de taxes pour avoir les
moyens de ses ambitions moi je pourrais
pas la acheter chez moi en ce moment je
préfère chez la maison où on est mais de
l'autre bien des résidences se demandent
s'ils ont les moyens d'être Montréal